[Applause]
Forza horizon is a series that has
always managed to definitely balance
accessibility and complexity it takes
the realistic driving mechanics of Forza
Motorsport fit ditches the intimidating
nature of professional racing and
ruthless competition instead it uses
vibrant locations and positive vibes to
amplify and celebrate the joys of
driving the giddiness of speed the awe
of vibrant scenery and the spectacle of
shiny cars
[Music]
what's the horizon for upholds this
tradition meaningful changes add
interesting gameplay considerations and
improve progression flow on top of it
already
accommodating difficulty options a
smorgasbord of vehicles and the
beautiful open world overflowing with
activities with horizon for playground
games continues to excel at making the
act of virtual driving exciting
approachable and entertaining without
sacrificing complexity horizons fourth
open world locale is a version of Great
Britain that amalgamates and condenses
iconic regions of England Scotland and
Wales offering some fantastic terrain to
explore the rolling hills of the English
countryside make cross-country driving
more thrilling the Scottish mountain
ranges offer breathtaking highway routes
and the city of Edinburgh is windy hilly
streets serve as an interesting location
for street races but the biggest change
to horizon is the introduction of
seasons horizons Britain cycles between
summer autumn winter and spring and the
weather in each season affects the world
in tangible ways these range from the
obvious like bodies of water freezing
over to the near imperceptible like the
change in temperature affecting your
tires but seasons truly require you to
adapt both your technique and your
vehicle and this variety produces a
unique dynamic the same course you drive
in summer will be buggy after an autumn
rain and asphalt roads will get slicker
during the winter snow
in the first few hours of horizon for
the seasons will change after you've
completed a number of activities and
this quick cycle reveals how necessary
it is to consider and adjust your
driving but once you complete a whole
cycle the implementation of seasons
changes they'll then be tied to an
online server synchronized for all
players and will rotate every seven days
online functionality has a larger
emphasis in horizon for when playing
solo the game will discreetly connect
you into an online session with up to 72
other players you can also form a convoy
with up to 12 people as well as compete
in rank or unranked team adventures for
seasonal prizes it's still easy to focus
on playing solo at your own pace and you
can still go offline completely and
drive against AI but horizons expanded
online functionality does offer
worthwhile activities to encourage you
to connect with other people
head-to-head races are now more
interesting against actual human beings
and the weekly change in weather comes
with a selection of limited time season
specific races and championships as well
as seasonal challenge missions horizon
also features recurring Forsyth on live
public events which puts the call out to
play it in a session to gather together
and cooperate to hit a combined score
pool in certain activities you'll earn
currency to spend in an exclusive port
tooth on shop if you're successful but
these events become tedious quickly as
you'll be running the same activity like
a single gift zone or a danger jump
repeatedly until the group hits the
score target it's a missed opportunity
of Forsyth on live events is just a tiny
scuff in horizons otherwise
comprehensive and inviting gamut of
activities irrespective of online
seasonal events there are a large number
of vehicular disciplines to pursue the
majority of which allow you the great
flexibility of shaping a racer around
your vehicle of choice though you'll
still need to use your best possible
cars in order to perform well in things
like drift and speed challenges you're
also now able to create your own custom
courses and the series is more creative
pursuits return with story missions
which featured things like stunt driving
and nicer Marge's to other racing games
and the entertaining if highly
choreographed showcase races against
things like planes trains and halos
warthogs
chalo actual Cortana do you read me I
heard you need a bigger Cortana two kilo
actual perfect timing we're all done
here and ready for desktop progression
has changed from four to horizon three
you no longer expand multiple festival
sites to uncover activities instead each
discipline has its own corresponding
progression meter participating in a
particular kind of activity enough times
win or lose we'll eventually level up
that discipline reward you and unlock
more activities of that kind on the map
it's an exciting and friendly system
that stretches you out to the farthest
reaches of the world quickly makes it
feel like something new and interesting
to do is always nearby and rewards you
no matter what you decide to participate
in and how you perform even after hours
and hours of play horizon for kept
revealing surprises by introducing brand
new styles of activities keeping the
game's flow feeling fresh it always
feels like there's a reward in reach too
with both individual meetings for
disciplines and an overall progression
meter you're often just a couple more
races away from earning a level up prize
the slot machine style wheel spins also
return now with a variant that lets you
pull for three prizes and thankfully
they still remain siloed from any
real-world monetary transactions horizon
4 has a larger variety of potential
rewards to the bigger focus on online
interactions means driver customization
is a big deal which throws in hundreds
of unisex clothing options quick chat
phrases and dance emotes into the pool
this means you might occasionally get a
boring prize like a pair of shoes but
the pace of compensation is steady
enough to make this negligible and also
makes the rare occasion of nabbing a
free car all the more satisfying
speaking of cars rise and fall boasts
100 more vehicles over its predecessor
with a total of 450 in the base game
while Japanese car enthusiasts will
definitely notice the absence of
Mitsubishi and Toyota vehicles
Volkswagen has held over from motorsport
7 as have a few new vehicles like racing
trucks once again horizon features an
array of tinkering options for
enthusiasts as well as order upgrade
options and a number of accommodating
driving assists for those who'd rather
only think about accelerating and
turning regardless of how you drive
vehicles feel way t-handle believably
and each one now has it
individual perk tree earning skill
points while performing both reckless
and prudent driving maneuvers will allow
you to unlock nodes that add buffs to
your skill point accumulation or earn
one-off rewards like wheel spins or
influence the games experience measure
its great change from our eyes in threes
global skill tree because it encourages
you to stick with a vehicle get to know
intimately and have the advantage of a
higher rate of reward skill points come
readily for driving at least somewhat
competently and you're free to use
points you earn on any vehicle which
makes swapping your go-to car less of a
blow to your progression if you've
already banked some extra points
horizons global perks have been
transferred to another new feature
properties which replace festival sights
as your garage and customisation hubs
finding and buying properties around the
map is relatively expensive but the
perks aren't contain are useful and
properties all act as valuable fast
shovel points fast travel still cost you
in-game currency at least until we find
and break all 50 fast travel boards that
are rising 4 does make other very
welcome improvements in the interests of
accessibility and quality of life
including the ability to change cars for
free and at any time there's such a
diverse range of activities stuffed into
every corner of horizon for and
meaningful changes contribute to smart
driving dynamics and a more consistent
sense of achievement
everything you do in horizon feels
valuable no matter how big or small
from the basic thrills of speeding a
fast car down a gorgeous mountain
highway to spending time tinkering with
your favorite ride to manage your
seasonal weary conditions to just
hanging out with friends and strangers
online and goofing off in some friendly
games the charm of the horizon series is
as palpable as ever
a winning all-inclusive recipe that
celebrates the joy of driving above all
else
[Applause]
you